My, my name is Mark,
and I am a cocreator
of a project
called Amazon,
which is an open
source data catalog
and metadata engine.
we'll talk a little
more about that.
I also started
a company recently
called Stemma.
And before that,
I was a product
manager at Lyft,
which is where I
created Amazon,
with a team, there.
And then, and before that,
I was a developer at Spark on
Spark at Cloudera
working on a few
different open source projects
in the Apache ecosystem.
Cool.
So I think before
we even start
talking about what I work on,
maybe it's important for us to
be on the same page
around the problem
that exists today.
So when I joined the this was
a common trend I saw there.
it becomes clear
to me that this
is not gonna be a big problem
in other organizations.
So take example of a data
scientist or an analyst,
and you can map out, say,
an analyst workflow
in four steps.
The first step is
discovery of data.
So I can, I can
use that data.
Next one, I explore
it to validate
it's the right thing
for me to do.
It's still being populated.
what does this
column contain?
So on and so forth.
The next step is the model
development and
productionization.
For an analyst,
this could be writing a SQL
query or generating
an insight.
For a data scientist,
this could be building a model
using the features that's,
that they've discovered
and explored.
And lastly, there's
the last step,
which is productionalization
slash visualization
slash communication.
And so what,
I found at Lyft
was that a third
over a third of their time was
being spent in
the first two steps,
discovery and exploration,
and the rest was
being spent in
the last two steps.
Now the thing to note here is
that the last two steps are
the ones that,
that we we paid
people money to do.
Right? This the this
is the hard part,
and the real world goes here.
But the first two steps around
discovery and exploration is
actually a huge time set.
So let me give you
an example of,
a data scientist at Lyft that
I vividly remember.
This data scientist was trying
to optimize for ETAs
of Lyft rides,
that were happening.
Now if you have
to create a new
model for ETAs,
you have to compare
it to the current
model that's in
production in ETAs.
Right? And you
know that an ETA
for a Lyft ride is actually
measured multiple
times throughout
the request journey.
So you open up your app.
You may see that your ride is
two minutes away.
You're going through
this request
funnel, and you find that this
ETA is often changing and
increasing sometimes.
and lastly, there
is the actual
ETA that when, like,
the driver gets
to you. Right?
And a company like
Lyft may have
experimented with
other models.
Some of those models may have
gone to production
for the ETA.
Some of them may have
been discarded.
Long story short, to find,
the the feature or the column
that has the current
ETA is, is really,
really hard. And
I hope you can
take this example
to your domain
and understand how,
how hard it is
to find a source
of truth for any single,
piece of information.
And one common concern that I
often got here was that, oh,
we just need to
document it better.
Right? But the fact that once
you have
a deeper understanding
of this problem, like,
you realize that
it's not simply
a matter of documentation, a,
because the documentation gets
out of date, but, b,
because these concepts are so
nuanced that you need,
more context
than documentation
can provide. So
this was a problem
that I saw at Lyft.
And what I wanted
to do was take
that thirty five percent time
spent in the first
two steps and
reduce that to as short as
possible so people could go to
the next two steps as quickly
as possible. Hope
that makes sense.
This problem actually led to
some secondary effect.
So there were these three
secondary effects.
The first one was
it led to a lot
of unknowns. So it
led to creation
of work that has been done.
So if you don't
know what the the
historical ETA trends are and
you wanna compare
them to the current
ETA trends,
you don't you can't
you don't know,
like, has someone
else done that
analysis before
around historical
trends?
Can I reuse it or update it
instead of start
it from scratch?
and then it leads to the a lot
of increased database load,
especially through
that exploration
step. So in
the exploration step,
you're doing a lot of select
star queries. You're trying to
do standard deviations
and stats.
You're trying to
see what the values
varies null and
distribution of
the column is.
All that stuff
can lead to a lot
of unnecessary redundant load
on the database.
And lastly, this
one is the most
subjective of all is it leads
to a heavy interrupt
culture. Right?
It's like me going to
share and be like,
hey. what is
the source of truth
for ETAs?
Which columns do
you usually use?
And it's just, like,
interrupt heavy,
like, not not grounded in fact
for truth. and that, to me,
was one of these
burning problems
at Lyft that, I
wanted to solve.
So there,
I started evaluating
solutions.
And, first was,
are there other companies who
have this problem?
And if so, what,
tools or products that have
these companies used to,
try to solve
the same problem?
So when I was looking
for solution,
it's important that, like,
the that the goals
for the solution
were clear. So first one was
that my belief
in the fact that
simple documentation
of getting
somebody to say,
like, hey, Thomas.
Every month, you
will go in and
make sure this
documentation is
up to date won't cut. Right?
So the three things
I was looking
for in solution was something
that will
automatically capture
everything related
to data endeavors.
Like, I know what
all data exist.
I know what
dashboards are built
on top of it. I
know what jobs,
ETL, and otherwise
are populating
this data. I know HR systems,
so I know all the employees,
what they access, and how.
Right? And I can build a graph
through all this
information and
then expose it in the right
places to the right people so
they don't have
to spend a third
of their time, like,
discovering and
exploring data.
Right? And so the first point
is building that graph.
The second point is it is ex
exposing that data in in user
friendly and meaningful ways.
And one could be
searching for ETS.
The other one could
be around lineage.
So often people wanna traverse
this graph. Right?
And people understand lineage
simply in terms of dataset to
dataset lineage,
but there's lineage
across these
different kinds. Right?
So I can go to my team leads
graph node and then be able to
traverse what
datasets they use,
and then from those datasets,
see what reports are built on
top of them and so
on and so forth.
And lastly, API.
This is important because you
can't anticipate
all the products
you wanna build early on,
and so you have to build open
APIs where people can access
this metadata and build other
products on it.
And lastly,
organizations and
data space is
always evolving.
Right? Like, five years ago,
the the orchestration tool of
choice was oozy, and
now it's Airflow.
Right? And five
years ago, like,
people used Hive,
and now it's Spark,
and the story goes on.
So it's very
important for this
metadata graph
to be integrated
well so that it
could extend to
new sources and new
classes of sources.
So new sources, I mean,
adding a new database.
But new classes of
sources, I mean,
adding a dashboarding
system or
adding Kafka topics
or adding an HR,
interface. Right?
And so I wanted this thing to
become the source of
truth for where,
what, how that data is stored
and used within
the organization.
when I started learning
more about it,
I found this paper
called Ground,
which you which you
may have heard of,
from from UC Berkeley.
And, they described it really
well in the sense that we were
capturing metadata.
And so when we talk
about metadata,
there were three
kinds of metadata
we're capturing.
First one is
application context,
which is where is the data,
what are the semantics
of the data.
Next one is behavior,
who's using it,
who created it.
And the third one is change.
How is the data
evolving over time?
The evolution of code that
generates this data.
What I found was
that the industry
was very good at capturing,
application context.
So you can catalog
all your datasets,
and there are plenty of tools
to do that. And
you can see what
the names and
columns and types
of those datasets are.
but when it started
to get to b and c,
behavior, who's
using that data,
who created that
data, this was,
like, really,
not there in most
of the commercial
tools out there.
And lastly, chain, like,
we we we didn't even we didn't
even grab our wrap our head
around this problem. Right?
And I I think that actually
continues to be the case.
and so,
then the other thing was what
datasets would you what things
would you gather
this metadata on?
And you could do
this on tables,
but you could add people to
the graph and dashboards and
ports to the graph.
And and the industry at that
point was somewhere
in the people
to dashboard marker.
You know, data
data stores were
pretty well done.
But when you start
going through
notebooks, so indexing your
notebooks and being able to
connect them to
the datasets or
schemas or streams, like,
that was pretty far out.
And so I looked at,
vendors in the space.
I looked at open
source solutions
in the space,
and I I found nothing
fit the bill.
And this is a complete
maybe a little
dated representation of what I
mean when I say
nothing fit the bill.
So there were ways to
grab the metadata,
there were ways to
expose the metadata,
and there were some concrete,
systems to integrate it with,
which were important to lift.
And then there
was a preference
to open source,
and and these are
the five tools
that were the biggest
in the running.
And, and you can see, like,
they they they fell short.
Right? And that led
to the reluctant
decision to start
a new project
in this space called Amundsen
or Amundsen.
hard to spell, hard
to write, but,
it is the name
of the project.
We thought it was appropriate
to to name the project after
the the first person to reach
both polls, and that
was Raul de Munson.
So, hope that makes sense for
the problem that existed,
and now we're gonna
start talking
about the solution and what
impact it's had.
so we'll start with, like,
the what the solution
looks and
feels and go into,
the architecture
of the solution.
so the the field for Amazon is
like a search engine for data
within your organization that
connects a bunch of things and
gives you the context.
So one thesis here is that in
order to solve this problem of
discovery and
trusting data that,
that you don't need
perfect data.
Right? I don't need
all the things
in one table so I can use.
What I do need is context on
the imperfections.
So if you could
tell me what are
the imperfections
around this data,
that I I'm smart
enough to figure out,
like, how I work
around them and
make it happen.
So that was one
of the key pieces
around the product.
Anyway, you come here,
you see a search box,
you type ETAs,
and you can get some results.
But often people
don't know what
to type.
So either they wanna
browse this data,
I only wanna see all
the marketing data,
or I wanna see all
the financial data,
Or they have certain
favorite tables,
that they have bookmarked.
They wanna browse that.
Or they don't even
know and they
just wanna browse
what's popular in,
in the organization
or the team.
So, so the front page,
the home page has
information like that.
I wanna speak one thing about
the popular tables,
and that is that,
popularity here is determined
by what's popular in
the query engines.
So Munson uses access logs and
query logs to determine,
popularity and is able to show
that based on what's queried
most heavily in the database.
Anyway, ninety
percent of the time,
people simply search here.
So you go inside that and you
type something.
You get a page rank
style search.
So, this is based on what you
typed on the table
as well as,
ranking based on how highly
queried those tables are in
the databases.
You click on
the dataset and you
get this page around
the dataset.
And this is where we start to
see some of the context
on the imperfections
, territory. So
you get the name
of the data set.
You see that this
is a data set
or a table, and then you see
that this is from Hive in case
there are multiple
databases in
the organization.
You see what
the description of
this table is.
This is actually obtained from
the underlying,
database, but you can,
edit it and you can send that
back to the database
if you like.
the next one is issues.
Often, what we find is people
aren't comfortable
users especially
aren't comfortable enough to
update the description
to say,
hey. This table
has this gotcha,
or I think this
may have a problem
from this date to that date.
So what we did was we created
an integration
with Jira so you
can report an issue.
It it takes you,
to a pop up box.
You file content to that.
It ends up creating a Jira.
It notifies the owners
of the table.
We'll talk about
how do we know
who are these owners.
And then it lists out
that issue here.
Right? And so other users can
start seeing if
there are other
unresolved issues and can make
their own
determination if that
makes sense to them or not.
Then you see date range.
So this is the first date for
which you have data,
the last date for
which you have data.
This is generated
automatically.
I wanna point out that most of
the information on this table
is automatically generated.
So how do we generate
date range?
This is a heuristic
based based
on the partition
scheme of the data.
So a lot of tables
in Hive have
date partition,
so we can look at the first
partition and
the last partition,
be able to, you know,
hypothesize what the first and
last date would be.
The next one is last updated.
This is when the last ETL job
populating this table actually
succeeded. oftentimes,
the date range and the last
updated are correlated,
but sometimes they're not.
You may have a weekly table or
a monthly table where the last
five jobs may have failed.
So those two, can
be can be off.
Then after that is
frequent users.
These are names of people and
email addresses and links,
profile links to
people who use
this table most frequently.
Again, this is obtained from
the database query logs.
Then you have tags.
these are, these
are API populated,
so you can hit
a hit a month and
with tags for a table.
And this often happens
in the context
of an ETL job. Like,
all financial ETL
jobs at the end
of the job will tag a month in
with a financial tag
for their data,
but you can also
update them in,
in the tool using
the UI tooltip.
and then, lastly, owners.
This is also updatable
via an API.
Many organizations sometimes
have an internal JSON file or
something on a per
schema or per
database basis
of owners or per
table basis, and
we script that
in into the tool.
But you can obviously also,
update this and keep this keep
this list up to date
within the tool.
Alright. So going
on to the right
hand side, you'll see
a list of columns,
their descriptions,
and their and their,
types. But you also
see dashboards,
and this is where we get to
dataset to dashboard
territory lineage.
so you can see what dashboards
have been built on
top of this data.
And if, say, you
were modifying
something in this dataset,
you can then go
start notifying
or reviewing how this data is
used and notifying
the downstream
dashboard owners.
on the top right side,
you see lineage,
and that is, an internal
tool that lift,
that is not a part
of, Amundsen,
and that has dataset
to dataset lineage.
So the same way Amundsen has
first class support for,
dataset to dashboard lineage,
it doesn't have
dataset to dataset
lineage support today,
and it's actually
a thing we are
actively working
on right now.
After that, you would
see a GitHub link,
which is the code that
builds this data.
it also has a link to the DAG
in cases where
it's applicable,
to the airflow job,
that builds this dataset.
Lastly, you can
preview the data
if you have access.
So if you have access,
you will see
a quick preview of
the data from
a recent partition.
And if this dataset is the one
you wanna use, we take you to
this explore button, which,
essentially populates
a skeleton query.
so it's like select star from
this table where, you know,
it selects the appropriate
database connection and so on
in a BI tool of your choice.
So at Lyft, this
was integrated
with Apache Superset,
which was the our BI tool.
And then,
and and but you can integrate
with any other tool.
Anyway, you can
click on a column.
You see stats. you
this is a preview
we talked about.
You can click on
the dashboards tab,
and you see that it shows that
there's one dashboard built on
this table.
You can click on
the dashboard here,
and you see the detail page of
the dashboard. So here,
you see that this
dashboard is for mode.
It was created
and last updated
on this date. Recent
view count is this.
When was the last run and last
successful run?
If you have access,
you can see the preview
of the dashboard
. And more interestingly,
you see what tables does this
dashboard use and what queries
does this dashboard,
use to query them.
And, obviously,
if you wanted to see
the real dashboard,
you could go to
the dashboard page,
which will take you to mode.
and here, you can also search
for your coworkers.
So you can type
a person's name and say,
in this example,
you type my name and you are
able to see what
datasets I own,
what datasets I bookmark,
and what datasets
I frequently use.
And this was pretty common,
especially for
new employees as
they or people
who change teams
for them to learn from other
people on the team before they
start going. Cool. Alright.
So we're gonna
now move on to,
the architecture
and then later
on talk about the impact this
product has had.
so in terms of architecture,
Munson has four, big pieces.
We'll start from
the top right.
Munson is a front
end service.
This is what you saw
in the UI thus far,
but interesting
stuff is obviously
in the back. So the two things
backing the front end service
are the metadata service on
the left center
side and the search
service on the right center.
so the metadata
service is this
graph that actually houses all
the metadata around,
what powers the tool.
So this is, you know,
a person is a node,
a table is a node,
a dashboard is a node,
and there are connections
between them.
we currently support Neo four
j as the default.
we also have support for,
Neptune from AWS as well as
Apache Atlas too.
And then the search interface
is powered by Elasticsearch,
and that's
a separate service.
All the,
secret sauce is
not secret around
how do we change the search
ordering based
on relevance and
popularity, and
that's all stored
in that search repo.
and then the fourth piece is
this database crawler.
We call it crawler.
It doesn't have
to be a crawler.
But, what this data builder
thing is is that
it actually is
an ETL system that
grabs metadata
from various sources,
databases,
dashboards, GitHub, airflow,
and puts it into
Neo four j and
Elasticsearch. And lastly,
I'll go to the top
left corner,
and that is
the microservices.
so not only can
you access this
metadata through a front end,
you can also access
this metadata
through other services.
And we find that, you know,
security and
compliance service
can use this to to make sure
that PII tags are
being adhered to,
against usage,
or ML feature service can use
it to replicate data between
online and offline stores,
so on and so forth.
One thing I wanna
talk about is
this data builder pull versus
push model. So a pull model is
where something crawls,
and this was
the the first model
that was true for
data builder.
In this case, the data builder
is very much like
how most people
think of Google
crawlers. Right?
You wake up every
so often, say,
four hours or twelve hours,
and you go to all
the databases
and you grab all
the updates and
you punch them into,
into the graph.
this is preferred if you have
a scrappy team
who wants to move
fast and not have dependencies
on each of the other
database teams,
that exists. But
the con of this
pull model is that,
it runs on a schedule,
which means your
metadata won't
be available until
that schedule is run.
So if you run every
twelve hours,
there may be
a twelve hour delay
when you, create a new table
because you're waiting for,
for the next run.
And then the push model is is
a is a place where
a database,
when a new, table gets created
or something like that,
pushes an event down,
an event pipe like Kafka,
and pushes that
into the graph.
Now this works really well if
you want near real
time indexing.
You don't want any,
any delay there.
It also provides us clean
interface that's between,
the database and
the graph so that,
if either one gets updated,
they just try to
make sure that
the interface is adhered to.
and the con, though,
is that usually
this this means
that you have to
have dependencies
on a bunch of different teams
and make sure they send you
events and so on
and so forth.
So Munson supports both.
it started with pull model and
now also supports push,
which is in beta.
However, most people currently
use pull because
of the historical
nature of the tool.
So supports both,
but wanted to share a little
more thought there.
And lastly, around
relevance and and,
popularity, wanted
to share that
if you search for
apple on Google,
right, like, if you get orange
as a result versus
the fruit apple,
like, that is low
relevance. Right?
If you got orange,
that's low relevance.
However, when you type apple,
you may actually
be searching for,
the computer company,
not the fruit.
Right? And this is
where the balance
comes in between
popularity and
relevance.
So not only do we wanna be
relevant and show
you the fruit,
we want to actually show you,
the the software
company, the product,
than the fruit because that's
more popular, for
people like you.
And this is
the same way we try
to do search in Amazon.
And so the way it
manifests is,
like, we measure
relevance against
the descriptions,
the table name,
the column names,
and the tags on the table.
And then we measure popularity
against scoring activity,
and we have different,
weights for automated activity
versus ad hoc querying.
and for dashboards,
we match against
description and
chart names,
and we measure
popularity based
on the number of
edits that are
happening on our dashboard or
the number of views
on our dashboard.
Cool. Lastly, the impact this
product has had,
so this is a graph from Lyft,
and it shows,
a month in having about seven
hundred and fifty
weekly active
users and a lot of,
table and employee pages.
you will find that
there is a drop,
for example, in
December twenty
nineteen, and that's that's
because of the holidays.
This graph is
a few months old.
but it's been going up up into
the right, and
a lot of analysts
and data scientists use it.
and and if you're
curious as to
who are the people
who are using it,
this is a a graph
of the penetration
rate at Lyft. So
you find that the,
the blue bar here represents
the number of such
people at Lyft,
and the red bar represents how
many of those used a Munson in
the last week.
And so you notice
that the blue bar
for a squeeze
or software engineer
is really high,
and then
the penetration rate,
the red bar, is only about
seventeen percent.
And that is because
most software
engineers don't use
Amazon day to day.
They are working on writing
mobile apps or,
building services.
However, there
are about twenty
percent or so who
are data engineers,
work with data all day long,
and these people
use it every day,
every week. Where you see high
penetration rate is
the next two items,
which is data scientists and
research scientists.
At Lyft, the data
scientist has
historically done
a little more,
decision, engineering
and decision
science work, while a research
scientist has done more ML
modeling work.
So both of those
users use anywhere
from seventy
to eighty percent penetration
rate in those, products.
And then you have
a long tail of,
like, lesser technical users,
so anywhere from
product managers
to community
associates who are
customer
service representatives
to economists, customer,
quality people,
and operations and marketing
people who use it.
But the usage there
is is very small,
and these are savvy people for
whom barrier to entry has been
lowered because
a a product like
this access that lift.
So Amundsen was
made open source
about a year ago and has over
a thousand community
members on Slack,
where it come coming from over
a hundred and
fifty companies.
twenty nine of those companies
are using it in production.
And so it's been
a great, great,
great, thing for
the product to
be able to help out,
other organizations.
We obviously have
a long way to
go and a long road
map of things
that we wanna do,
but we've been grateful for to
have an amazing community and
continue to work with
them in order to,
deliver value for
these organizations.
To give you a sense
of who uses Amazon,
you've got, Reddit,
I n g, Square,
Workday, Asana,
and many others
who are in this
category. And then
there's an active
community of much
larger organizing
that's much larger than those
organizations, in
terms of number
of companies,
who also use it.
And, I can give
you a little bit
of sense of what
the future looks like.
So what I was trying to do was
to develop this application
around data discovery
and trust,
like reducing
the time it takes
people to discover and trust
the dataset they wanna use.
That's the leftmost
part of this
diagram.
And what I found was
as I was building,
this, this tool this product
that I that we
ended up gathering
a gold mine of
metadata. Right?
This is a graph,
in the API and the opinionated
products that you can build on
top of this graph.
So, once we started
doing that,
we saw that there were other
people who started
using the same
graph for other adjacent
applications that we
hadn't thought of.
So I'll I'll share
one example of that,
which is in the security and
privacy space.
Square, who uses Amazon,
doesn't use it for
data discovery
and trust. They
actually use it
for privacy engineering.
They tag all their
data in Amazon
with PII or NPI tags and then
use these tags
to create person
specific views in Snowflake.
So when I go to Snowflake,
I can only see
the right columns
based on what I'm
allowed to see
in my role, and
I know what data
is PII versus not
based on what's
stored in Amazon.
and the way they tag this data
in Amazon is through,
Google DLP API
and a combination
of internal tools that place
the guest on confidence level
of this column is
likely a PII.
For columns that have
low confidence,
they have extended the amounts
in user interface to cater to
a security analyst persona who
gets a notification
and is then
able to approve or reject that
that proposal,
for a column being
PII or not.
and so what I see
in the future
is that this
metadata will lead
to a lot of interesting other
applications like
we are already
starting to see in Amazon.
But, it is,
there's obviously a lot to do
in every single of these every
single one of
these applications
as well. So what
we call Amazon
today is both
the data discovery
and trust application as well
as the metadata,
the horizontal metadata bar at
the bottom.
And so when it
comes to specific,
to the specific
to the the data
catalog or data
discovery application,
we find that having dataset to
dataset lineage is
important and having,
ACL integration is
also very important.
So only certain users can edit
descriptions, so
on and so forth.
So lastly, to summarize,
data discovery
is a huge pain.
That's the plane we tried to
solve by creating a Amazon.
but we are seeing
that this pain
actually can the solution here
can be used to solve other
adjacent pains around access
control and security
and privacy.
And so I wanted to
leave you all with,
these four links.
The first one is a website to
amazon amazon dot I o,
and you can you can use the QR
code there. The next one is
the code to the project.
The third one is,
a a recent blog post that I
wrote that describes this gap
that exists between production
and consumption. Right?
Like, data engineers
are producing data,
and it's going to
this data lake,
turning it into data swamp.
And on the other side,
data analysts and
data scientists
want to use
trustworthy data for
their work and don't
have the right
the right dataset
to do that work.
And so, there's this gap,
and it talks about how how why
this gap exist and how we can
solve for that gap.
And lastly,
the fourth blog post
is a blog post from Square on
user privacy and how they are
using Amazon to
drive that forward.
that's all for me.
I would love to hear what you
think and if you
have any feedback,
for me or the project.
So, Mark, first of all,
congratulations for setting up
this open source community.
Have there been any
surprises like,
contributions,
and where are you
seeing
interesting contributions
to the the the code? Yeah.
that's a good question.
I think there are two things
that are interesting
observations.
The first one is,
a surprise around,
like, how others have started
to use this prop product.
and we we were
all very focused
on data discovery
and trust and
the Square contribution and
taking the direction
of helping
it out with,
security and privacy
engineering was a,
a really,
really good use case that we
haven't thought of,
initially at Lyft.
And the second one is that I
find that most of the core
contributions to the project
still happen from a very small
group who, have
been working on
this project and
who are deeply
invested in the project
by the number
of engineers who work.
But most of the contributions
actually are perhaps,
by design happen,
on the outskirts,
which is integration.
So Lyft will, for example,
add more integration,
but, you know,
someone else would want to
integrate with Tableau
or or Looker,
and they will come
and add that.
same thing with databases.
So we find that we're getting
a lot of value,
through through,
being being able to integrate
with all these systems,
by having a really
amazing community.
And that's a really,
that's the thing
that the project
is very grateful for. Great.
and I if you've timed later,
I'd encourage you to come on
the Slack and just
share it with
you on the KG
conference community.
We have over eleven hundred
members across the globe.
So I think this would be we've
been promoting this,
but I think it'd
be great if you
could share it there
as well and just,
how people can
access it and and
get involved.
Any any other
questions for Mark?
Just while we're
waiting, Mark,
did you say you
founded the company
interested in what
you're you're
up to next? Yeah.
I found that,
many organizations
can use open source to solve
this problem,
but there's there
are quite a few who,
don't wanna don't wanna deal
with the open source and,
don't have
the the right engineers
and priorities to to
make that happen.
So, the name of
the company is Stemma,
and I I cofounded that to help
every single
organization solve
these problems.
And Amazon would be right at
the front and center of this
company and, contributing to
Amundsen and
making that better
and providing value
for open source,
community members
is important.
And this company
will help help,
move that forward
even faster.
But it will also help larger
organizations,
the ones that we
couldn't have
an impact to open
source to help solve
the same problems.
Okay.
And in your list there,
I saw some larger
organizations,
some financial
services institutions
who tend to be,
more risk averse
around open source.
are you seeing some
traction there,
and and, you know,
how is that engagement from
larger institutions
going? Yeah.
We've seen some
engagement there.
So ING is the large financial
institution who's
a user of Amazon.
and, for them,
it's, you know,
forward thinking
large financial
organizations will
will set this
thing up and and
then play with it,
iterate, and move move this
forward and
evaluate it against
what they have.
what I do think
happens in those
organizations is,
they have a lot of
specific needs.
some of them are regulatory.
Some of them are
legacy related
because of
the systems they have
and the processes
they've already built.
And, I think we have a lot of
work to do in in
the open source and,
and as a community to,
have a larger integration net
and be able to support those
specific requirements.
Great. and it's like,
how best can our
community help?
Yeah. I I think
the best the the
few things that the community
can help is, like,
if you see this
as a problem in
the organizations and the data
you work with,
I'd encourage you
check out Amundsen,
and I can I can share
links to that,
in the Slack
channel as well as
you mentioned, Thomas?
And then, as you
get to evaluating
and trying out Amundsen,
join the community
Slack channel,
which is Amundsen
and be able to ask questions,
share feedback, and share,
your thoughts for the project
so we can keep improving it.